[Music]
breaking at 4 30 major rain falling
causing flooding in the southwest part
of the valley metro police confirming
several cars are stuck near decatur and
silver router ranch and in different
pockets of the valley people are just
leaving their cars behind we do thank
you for staying with us i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis now
monsoonal downpour to blame for that
flash flood happening in the southwest
valley 8 news now tonight we have team
coverage jerry brown is in the weather
center tracking all that moisture jeremy
j ford live over at blue diamond and
rainbow we're going to first check in
though with victoria saha joining us
near decatur and silverado ranch with
the latest on the situation victoria
yeah brian and denise it's been about an
hour here the roads have been closed but
you can see the water is still flowing
up east police are here trying to divert
traffic we also saw public works on
scene they really don't want anyone
nearby driving through the water because
it is dangerous just a few minutes ago
there was a car that was stuck for a
while looks like they just moved it
traffic has been going into that chevron
station to get away from the water but
of course you see a metro cop trying to
make their way through again they really
don't want anyone here they don't know
when this road will be cleared up but
for now they just want drivers to just
take precaution if you're driving this
way just know that you cannot drive
through let's check in with jeremy j
ford he's by rainbow and decatur jeremy
what's it looking like out there where
you are
that's right victoria i am here at
rainbow and decatur and like you said
there were cars stuck in this area as
well just moments ago there was a high
water rescue right off of rainbow that
ended up where a woman was driving
through or down rainbow and her car
actually cut off after her car cut off
she was rescued safely by emergency
response and then called for a tow truck
driver to come get her car out now
luckily she is safe and the tow truck
driver ended up coming on in and then
actually just driving her car
the safety but i want you guys to come
over here with me because what you can
see as of right now traffic is open
again but right here the water still
continues to go down underneath the
roads to keep the roads safe but it's
definitely still flowing heavily within
this area now one more thing i did speak
to metro and metro told me to remind the
public that during storms they should
slow down and drive with carson so now
let's send things over to jerry brown
who's tracking more storms across the
valley coming our way jeremy that looks
like a little river behind you we're
used to seeing flood stuff out here in
mohave county it's a little more serious
when it gets closer to home and we do
have a flash flood warning until five
o'clock up the 15 toward utah and also
just to our northeast and it does
include part of the valley the extreme
northeast valley that is until 5 45 as
flooding has been reported and heavy
thunderstorms over the southwest valley
caused that area to be under the flood
advisory and that also extends down the
15. that's until 5 15 this afternoon now